sometimes ideas seem great like the
Queenie attic trampoline as a kid and
you know you're an adult now and
everyone tells you you're too old for
trampolines but you decide you know what
I'm a grown man let me get a trampoline
and then your wife tells you that it's a
waste of time and a waste of money and
you don't listen to her obviously you
tell her you're gonna level level the
yard you tell her you're gonna use it
all the time and you lied because you
never do and then you're finally gonna
have to take it down it's a sad day but
before we do before we take this bad boy
down the the trampoline that was never
jumped on I'm gonna prove to myself and
to everybody watching that I can do a
backflip now I know what you're thinking
Steven that nobody can do a backflip
that's a myth it was until today okay
now don't worry I've got my safety crew
standing by right over there he's
watching very closely Barney show him
how good you are sit sit
he's not in the mood but he's ready if I
mess up he's ready to come get me all
right let's do this
oh there it is the first ever backflip I
know my last day with the trampoline -
it's a shame imagine what we could have
done together if I tried at all